hello beautiful people how is it going welcome to all the new students
one in chat i know that some of you are already printing
guys to the new one okay to the new user we have um we have a bunch of people that don't know the
quality we bring and what we do here can you help me to welcome them because they are used to
pre-recorded courses with no live action and they don't know maybe what we are doing here
nice nice nice nice let me share the screen guys for you
this is the first live of the week
to be honest
i am already playing with the market i took one quick scalp let me show for you let's go
on the share screen should be visible guys tell me if it's visible i took a crazy sniper
it's it's live guys can you please confirm that it's live there are people that say
maybe it's uh it's delayed this is live this is the sniper i took pre-market i'm covering my stop
loss above here and i want to show you how i'm managing the trades now this one is not a triple
a it's a aa and there is a level from where the price could react here okay but let's say that it's
low risk already covered stopping profit but if it goes well guys it's 11 000 of profit so it's nothing bad
now while these setups continues to go
it's not easy to to trade live and we need to go to the disclaimer i hope every one of you read it
previously uh anyway uh it's the service it's for educational purpose okay i share with you my experience
uh it's not financial solicitation i'm not an advisor and i'm trying to train you on how the market really
moves giving you the instrument and the education on how to do this yourself okay and uh you you need
to be aware that futures market cfd markets options market involve risk that can excess also the uh
amount of the account so please don't do anything that you are not sure uh what's the risk on the
position and be prepared look at people already took the same i had the same shot but i got stopped in
profits and you know that i think i also will get stopped in profits because now the volatility will
start to kick in now the volatility will start to kick in soon in uh 15 minutes but i think it could
be nice it could be nice to show also how i manage the stopping profit in my position so if i have
something to share with you i think it can only be benefit for you to to see me doing this live what
do you think the deep trade when it's pre-market guys the the deep trade is 20 because pre-market 20
it's what works best you can do 20 or 30 if you are already in the trade you can scale to 20 so you can
understand whether you see absorption you see i'm covered above this absorption for two thousand
dollars in profit and i expect the market to have a little bit of reaction here so my take profit it's
a little bit excessive for the the volatility at the moment but i think i'm really good at reading the
bias the only problem is that during the opening you have a really strong fight between buyers and
sellers and it's possible that even if the direction is is clear they will take out my stop loss okay
yeah 20 20 guys 20 we had inside today yesterday would you go over it so why did you take of course
we will go on a breakdown of the setup but guys today i decided to start before because i wanted to
give you more value so now i'm doing checkup because i have a problem with my stomach i'm bleeding i don't
know what the it's happening i hope the market maker are not poisoning me but anyway there is no
way that i will cancel the live so i say considering i have a check up later i will anticipate the live
and we will do the opening together so you get some value on how to manage also the the session opening
okay and um at the moment we are watching the live interaction between market participants they
try to break up of this level again of course later we go to theory guys of course later we cover also
theory of all the setup and what we trade here for the new people you find in the section that it's
called um it's called neural pattern recognition exactly every setup that i execute okay so i created
this to make it to make it visible for you also what we are searching what we consider also that i
usually prefer to trade during the new york session okay so what i do during the uh what i do during the
london it's uh it's necessary to have different settings okay and these settings is 20 or 30 it depends
on what's the interaction at the moment between the the market participants usually it's 30 for execution
or 25 and 20 for managing the trade yeah 60 60 it's fixed i always use 60 during new york session
always use 60 okay now they are trying to break above this level again you see this absorbed i i i asked the
the the service to put my live streaming in full hd is it clearly visible this absorption here guys
yeah of course you have the recorded session justin it's on the q1 you can see everything okay so so
the buyers try to try to breach this level this point of aggression of the sellers that created this
breakout and you see that now there is a liquidity wall here and the liquidity will well it's kept by
the buyers so what happens now we have two chance either during the opening okay they manage to go above
and we are stopping profit so we don't care we still take some profit out of the market or if we bridge
through this level okay and we manage to have enough aggression to arrive here we we can our target
becomes possible okay i know it's really high target low target in this case but it's it's possible that
the market reaches and i'm trying to capitalize on also the volatility of the opening session
i can see what you are trading i'm always trading nasdaq guys always and only trading nasdaq okay
no problem how should we decide sometimes i'm having problem about understanding catching the beginning
uh can you be more specific on uh yeah now we set at 20 viva can you be more specific on what do you
mean catch the beginning like you mean the beginning of the move or the opening of the session
antonio saying fabio i'm getting profitable i'm feeling it guys how many people notice a change in
their equity line from the service one in chat how many people look at the chat for the new one okay
now i think the main reason they are seeing benefit it's because i explained to them that
they should never give back profit to the market now in this case if the market goes up if the market
goes down it's not a problem for me okay because either way i make profit because i made a great
analysis i'm and i'm taking the two thousand dollar out okay so the question now it's two thousand dollars of
profit or twenty or twelve thousand dollars of profit this is the real question and sometimes i
feel that people are more interested in validating their ego than making exceptional trades so they
they are more interested guys in being right and they forget to take profit they forget to take profit
maybe they just wait for their analysis to go one to ten and the market always come back
there is someone there is someone guys that experienced this problem
yeah amazing now you can see guys that the sellers want the interaction the sellers want
the interaction here i'm really scared about this area i'm really scared about this area i think
during the opening a little bit of reversal here is possible let me check
let me remove the deep trades let me check what we have here oh you know what it's a little bit empty
yes we have a little bit of absorption on the downside here there is a little bit of absorption on this area
this can be a wall but still i don't see a lot of volume inside i don't see a lot of volume so it's
possible that during the opening they slice through it like butter you see the majority of volume is
positioned on the absorption on the distribution phase i think this one it's a weak low it's a weak
low and it's not enough strong to hold the opening let's see together i think it's not enough to hold the
opening this is a counter trend trade this one we will go through it later but this one it's a pure
orderful trade based on the distribution we will go through it together okay we will go step by step on
understanding the trade now i want now i want to see the interaction now they are getting in the level
that i'm afraid of what an amazing setup guys what an amazing setup
they are starting the absorption here they are starting the absorption
let's see what they can do anyway we don't care stopping profit guys and
we are not let's make 2000 run number okay you see that they are not having an easy time breaching
through okay see that every time they try bam bam bam they get absorbed
yeah it's the value area but we will go step by step andrea now i just want to show you because i think
there is a lack of this in the industry like there is no one showing you live account traded not prop live
account traded in front of your eyes that you can see and they manage without delay this is it's not
common guys it's not i've never seen it this was the service that i was searching when i started and i've
never seen no one giving something like this to me okay even charting it's okay charting it's okay but at
least some tree to understand how they manage you see the aggression is absorbed now look how much
is precise the level that we mark okay and here we have a really strong level also now in 10 minutes
13 minutes we have the opening and they see that in this interaction the sellers are really aggressive
so i can expect that they slice it through and when they slice okay when this lies i have enough speed
to go to take profit okay i have enough speed to go to take profit let's see
yeah i can see also from price the sellers are in control but i can see also that
this level is really strong guys and during the opening
during the opening is not so guaranteed that they will continue down okay now if i need to be greedy
i take this profit out how much is it seven thousand six thousand six hundred sixty six devil number i take
out okay and that's it but i want to show you the trade management okay it's not a big number for me
if it goes back to break even is still two thousand it's not a problem i want to show you how i manage
also the opening okay now the data provider is called digspeed it's having a little bit of problem
recently i don't know if someone else experienced during the market opening the a little bit of delay
in the data feed in the beginning i was thinking it was my connection so i tried to refresh then i contacted
them and they uh they opened one platform they had some problems with the big speed uh i hope we will
not have it but anyway it's it's not impacting the order like the order feel at the level it's just data
okay just the data you can see during the opening here on the red delay three seconds delay four seconds
it's the last two sessions that it's opening it's it's happening and that's the reason i'm investigating
let's see the sellers are trying again i think the market maker don't like this movement guys this is
not the kind of movement that is appreciated by the market maker so i'm pretty sure we will rebalance it
and during the opening i would like to see something like this tap
and then from here
this is the opening i expect let's see even better if they go before opening guys even better
i am not so aggressive with stopping profit alex because it's pre-market and the liquidity is thin
so a small aggression can bring the price back here and then back down and it's really i don't know
it's it's not a big size for me it's not changing my life ten thousand dollars of realized profits so i
wants to i wants to bring the the analysis to the end i want to bring the analysis to the end let's see
yeah i think it's useful to see the the management in real time but i still think we will not go down
from here we will go up again during the opening here they go here they go we will reach this box
that is where the price interacted in an inefficient way and then from there they will take back control
that's my analysis let's see let me remove this let me check this is the absorption level so the control
of the buyers and then we want to see what's the last point of aggression the last point of aggression
that is relevant is this one that is where the imbalance is set okay you can see all this inefficient
perception okay and you can see this two point of aggression here okay so as i told you market maker
don't like movements with thin liquidity okay so this movement here that you saw needs to be rebalanced
there is a high probability that we will see the balance then after you see something like this
it's more probable that they manage to reload during the opening nine minutes
i love the stream at 3 pm with the opening yeah guys today i managed to do like this because i don't
want to do only one hour of stream i want to do more so i i i try to fit in at my best
okay now you know what pattern could be really interesting here it can be really interesting and
absorb buyers now you see the volumes are starting to build the volume are starting to build and you
see that now the sellers are absorbed this is not a good sign for our setup okay it's not a good sign
because the sellers are at the top and if the candle break if the candle break and they don't take
back control the buyers can bring the price back to these two levels i will mark all the battle
i will mark all the battle
here
see they try to take back control
now you know what with the volatility of the opening if we manage to slice through it it will
not be so stupid to find a level where we can cover our stop loss at 5 000 in profit
it's irrelevant in london session i just want to see the information it's irrelevant in london session
for new york session we use the usual template guys the usual template with the numbers now i
want just to see colors because i need to take fast decision okay so for example if they manage to get
aggressive now the buyers and they slice through and they're right here and they have an absorption
it's more important for me to see the color who asked this uh ms is it clear guys i asked you
something can you put the name you make my life really difficult i already need to manage and watch
the chat i need to have a name not a number not a fantasy ms it's important for the quality of the
life and if you want an interaction where i can reply please put a name put a name so you see we
have this horizontal level where the sellers manage to protect to protect nice the area okay they manage
to protect the the area in a really good way yes it's cho francisco francisco i can see your name
uh when there are opportunities yes not common but when there are opportunities yes when the market
opens and we have a little bit of bidding guys trust me it's really difficult to have the volatility of
the market opening watch the chat reply to you chart and manage it's like sensei skill yoda level of
management okay now let me finish this one okay and then we go to the theory of the setup but before
let me finish this one now it's getting cluttered you see the volume is getting high the volume is
getting high look at this volume look at this volume look how much aggression the buyers put in this
movement they will go here they will go with high probability here because this is the next sensitive
level that we can have on this side the sellers are like no no no you don't go through i protect you
don't pass through okay ah i didn't told you the five minutes before the auction opening it's always
relevant it's always relevant guys for example if this candle close with absorption
i can take 5 000 out 5 700 out now we are really relaxed guys we don't care at all why i did this
because i saw the interaction let me put a little bit down i saw the interaction on this level and i
saw that the buyers attempt a big aggression and they failed okay
they failed yeah i can promise you that you get more value if you let me explain because
live interaction is really valuable guys it's really valuable okay
now it's all cluttered i can only see that the aggression got stopped on the same horizontal level
and we have this absorption now if this gets sliced through during the opening you know what i get i
get a squeeze now we have to see if this can accept but it's funny that i say and it does it
this is funny and now this one seems like a failed auction okay so if this is a failed auction i will
take stopping profit it's okay i need to be fast to remove my take profit let's see let's see how it
goes no it's not delayed so a big absorption from the buyers a big absorption from the buyers
and now they will try to slice through the level that's the reason if they fail again i don't want
and if they break i take another 2000 out of the market what's the problem
there is absorption here guys there is a lot of absorption now i don't have the time to take
other information on the market but there is a huge absorption okay make sense that if they
get absorbed again we close because this one is a wall and during the opening during the opening guys
this will most probably hold this will most probably hold let's see three minutes let's see this aggression
again you see
look at the precision of the level we put guys look at the precision of the level we put got absorbed one
tick above
look at this this is the importance of the level that you mark
absorb the game let's close
okay why i don't want to risk this i don't want to look at this we had the stop loss here look at this
the precision of the level that we marked okay why i i didn't hold my position because the risk
here is that you get slippage you know what is slippage guys the slippage i think the analysis is
correct i think we will slice through but slippage is that if we are wrong they take more profits
than expected i think during the opening guys the market goes here let's see
no no no no no no beautiful or no
yeah we took eight thousand dollars it's okay
it's okay
it's amazing guys this absorption will hold
now look at this look at the opening let me mark for you the level look at the opening
one minute to the opening mark this level
the sellers won the battle
now
now either this absorption okay show up at this level okay so they managed to recover this
or it collapsed guys collapsed 30 bam
look at the precision of the level
reloaded
look how this level is holding guys
second one there one
reloaded in the middle absorbed
what an amazing auction let me put it more clean for you now we can use our usual template
guys how is the experience for the one that are starting
huh huh now the market can go long
this guy made three thousand guys but please don't execute this i'm trying to teach here
look at the perfection this auction is the one that i told you the absorption will hold okay
the absorption will hold now i'm thinking about executing again
um
it will have been a short in this case
we continue down we go to the next station guys we go to the next station and here you see a
slippage why you see a slippage because all these orders get fucked so slippage to the next round level
this level is the 25 800
900 was an option level amazing
hey we continue down guys continue down
you know down we saw all the auction down from here
yeah
yeah yeah yeah but you know the slip the slippage can be really dangerous guys because you can
it can take out more uh risk than what you want to put in the market so it's better to take
8 000 instead of 11 but be safe okay be safe
now if you go on the neural pattern recognition can you see this
can you recognize this interaction that we had here
yeah now we got more to long-term analysis
i think it's funny to do the opening together i think we should make one time per week the opening
thing together it's a lot of volatility no it's not a field adoption it's not a field adoption
the sellers are in control guys they are just reloading on the 310
they will continue you have another leg down
look at this reload look at this reload look at this reload like these setups are not easy to take
okay this setup are not easy but all the reloading phase above the the big order is really profitable
really profitable guys okay all the reloading phase now i show you in the live interaction
how does it work okay let's say that they break this one i want to see the candle close
okay i mark the level but i wait for the candle to close okay
you see this is an absorption level now what happens that if the candle close and slice through it
this is where they come to reload okay this is where they come to reload at least they try
what an amazing auction what an amazing auction that is
now let's go on the reason why i expected a short explosion you want to go step by step how i do this
or you want more to chart now and to see the analysis what you prefer because i can because now i will not
start from this imbalance down because we are really low in the curve so considering that we need to
to wait a little bit of time okay because on here if i want to take a setup i will at least wait for
the market to reach the 310 okay at least because we but it's coming wait wait
it's coming it's coming wait a second
okay
super directional today super super directional
it's 310 you see 310 contracts here and now you need to see the interaction okay because this
interaction is really important to let you understand if there are also passive order that
are willing to absorb the movement okay and these 310 passive orders are telling you look that in the
aggression that you have here we are the biggest
okay we are the biggest so in this case
the major possibility to continue the auction down it's from them if you break this level you go up
guys i hope it's good the quality but it's visible the mid level the 310 the week how much
is precise can you see this clearly or it's blurry because it's really important that you see this
unfolding in lifetime okay now what happens that this is the power they needed to reload and now when
they reload on the passive level they accelerate okay so it means that when they crash this level and
they go back to this one okay and they create a new auction they accelerate and you see a huge
acceleration here and when you accelerate for huge acceleration i mean that you create new dealing range
contained between the white level and the weak okay you see that they are still trying their best to push it
down and the passive order passive liquidity it's protecting is the same situation that we saw before
here is the same situation guys the same exact situation now what happens that when you crack the level
you have another down move really strong okay so when you get aggressive enough on the level on the level
you accelerate and you squeeze even down guys this session it's 10 out of 10 this session is 10 out of
10 trust me you learn more from this than anything that you do alone
i told you from the beginning sale how you can participate on the 310
i told you in all the auction if you want to join the short it's on this horizontal level
guys i was clear yes or no you see people took it that was crazy mate 3r this other guy took an
amazing short i explained to you how the auction unfold very clearly look at the chart
if you take the short the stop loss guys it's really close okay either you wait for this candle
to close and cover above or you take this step into and you cover above the week mamma mia
and now now now i'm thinking that guys if i kept the short opens and reload here another 10 contracts
we will have close 50 000 so you need really to love me so much to be careful with the chat and accept
8 000 to spend time with you probably took based on 40 range look amazing it's an it's an amazing it's
an amazing trade trade yeah it's correct the one you published christine it's correct
the guy in italian roberto never seen something like this in trading
amazing guys okay now don't be greedy okay i took a huge risk to reward the risk
2000 to make eight from the top we saw all the reload phase okay now don't be too greedy guys
because this market is over standard okay what does it mean that they need to rebalance a little
bit so you will have a little bit of retracement you will have a little bit of retracement on this one
what will you look for next now i don't see anything that is valuable you see james what i
want to teach you guys all is to avoid getting overexcited because when you get overexcited and this
is really common for scalpers you want you always want to take a setup now if if i will say to you
guys look you can take okay you can take two set up one continuation from when we watch on this
absorption okay that i show you the management side by side and this one per day two amazing setup
will you will this be enough for you or no it's enough guys trust me you don't need to do a machine
gun you don't need to take seven eight ten twenty five setups quality setups you see now the auction
is changing a little bit the buyers here are getting the sellers sorry are getting absorbed because you
have the 101 on the bottom let me mark this level because it's interesting for me okay what does it
mean that an aggression that is bigger than the previous one it's being kept by the buyers so this one
it's a level that is dangerous okay i mark in green let's see how they act
you notice what happened guys you notice that they came back and they needed to reload on the 92.
this is how the auction move huh they came back they reloaded and now they say now you can go
the sellers are still in control bam bam lock and reload
oh my god what a session guys
yeah yeah i i just read it for you james is it clear what they say in a way
what an incredible session
now you know what why i laugh you know why i laugh because this is the kind of session that makes the
portfolio manager go crazy because they see uh 0.5 percent one percent loss in the portfolio accounts
and we are making money on the atf guys panicking on the collapse of the nasdaq isn't this amazing
what happened is in this auction guys all buyers on the line absorbed all buyers on the line absorbed
okay what does it mean it means that they really try to bring it back to 101 and they failed
these are all break and reload break and reload break and reload they will push back again on the low
and here it is guys it's remote control today nasdaq it's remote control
yeah exactly lorenzo lorenzo is asking in italian he asked me and then you see
guys how many of you are new here can you put two in chat if you are new if you just joined
okay now my big goal
it's look how many new people okay my big goal for this community is to make it possible
and this is the most difficult part for people to understand what i do explaining in simple terms
and preparing them for cat roya
guys i hope someone took this while i was talking
what i was saying i forgot i forgot my james made 2k killing these shorts 700 guys how many of you paid
back for the the membership one in chat look at this guy made four thousand one in chat
amazing
i tripled it amazing guys okay now let's get concentrated because we are only 40 minutes in
the session and already we took six or seven setups all take profit don't get excited okay don't get
excited now what i wanted to explain to you is the following if you are new the biggest goal for me will be
that in the first lesson you come prepared with the section neural pattern recognition and you are
understanding the reason behind the setup is it like this for someone already for first lesson
are you understanding everything i say how i manage my trade the reload that we had can watch everything
perfect
amazing good guys now you see what they did the buyers try to step in on the movement and the sellers here
reloaded okay now they didn't touch the 490 they are trying to push around them now see for the candle
okay see for the candle if they close with a week and they don't go above 490 they strike back to the 61.
if they close above with a full candle the 490 okay they go to load on the 85.
okay this is how the interaction move okay how much is this amazing to see it live okay they try to
break through reload from the sellers and absorption okay now where they go they go to spike on the 61
with high probability okay the candle is still not closed that
makes so much sense it's based on auction it's based on auction so what we are saying now is that
if these sellers get broken they are forced to close and the power of 500 contract closing here
will push the price back to 85 you see that the buyers are still pushing they are trying to bridge
this level but you can see when you see this up and down up and down up and down up and down is the
power of the buyers pushing to the 490 wall and the sellers reloading reloading reloading reloading
they see the auction down it's a fight guys it's a fight okay who is trying to push the price up the
buyers that they are managing yes why they are managing because there is a big probability that
this candle close long okay you see that it now is spending more time on the top the first one got
rejected the first one got rejected the second one is going on the top second one is going on the top
and i cannot watch also the chart guys i would like to to have three fabio on me but i don't
okay now they are validating the 85 if they break the 85 guys we have a reversal from the bottom level
okay and this is the reason i told you when we are down in the curve and you continue to take every
single short the problem is that sooner or later guys you will have a reversal now it's not this the
case okay because they already show another absorption of this level but the market like to rebalance
okay probably we have a setup here let me see if i can join with you
no still too much power from the buyers
wait one second concentrated on the interaction
let me put the speed of tape because i see the sellers now are really weak it's flipping
the auction speed of tape
buyers in control you see last three candle at least
for the short term now let me remark everything
this is a really important decision level and this is what i was checking i was checking if this
area can be a protective pivot for us to go up again on the downside what i don't
like that the buyers are still like that the buyers are still controlling
later i go to the charts guys if you want to do live charting
and live trade management you need to be patient because i'm only one
striking again on the absorption true rejection already
let's see
yeah it seems that they are loading
let me see if i can shoot one here
one another one we put on the top
and we cover above let's see how they behave we are risking only the profit
the sellers got absorbed here i don't like it the sellers got absorbed so at the first aggression we
needs to be covered this absorption of the sellers is making the buyers control
more probable i cover here
risking a small amount
let me remove this that is bothering me
if they break i go risk free uh the sellers are absorbed so let's are absorbed
see sure down basically okay let's see
people
are
61 is the striking point that can bother me
Aggressively trail.
Getting to the hard point for the sellers to take control.
Take more profit out, 5000.
If it breaks, they explode.
Look how much absorption there is here, guys.
It's really difficult for buyers.
Isn't this amazing or no?
Made another 5000.
We close at 10,000 today.
Guys, I've never tried to manage and watch the chart and explain what I'm doing.
It's really difficult.
I hope you like.
I hope you understand how much this is more valuable than 1000 dollars.
Okay.
How much this is more valuable.
I really wanted to show because someone in the chat asked me, Fabio, how can I take it?
Did I reply to you on this one?
Now, I don't even know where it is on this one.
It's still valid anyway.
It's still valid, the setup.
It's still valid.
1000.
What do you expect the balance market?
It was me, Fabio.
Jason, did I help you on understanding how you can execute, manage?
Is it useful for you?
Amazing.
Yeah.
Guys, we are one hour in the session.
How many setups we watched today?
There is Bogdani, 6.4 thousand for today.
Amazing.
How many setups?
Yeah, it felt like 10 minutes because we have a lot of action.
Josh, where can we expect the retracement?
The buyers are not...
You see where they reloaded.
You see where they reloaded the buyers at the bottom of the curve.
Okay.
I still think we can have an explosion.
I still think we can have an expansion up.
Amazing, guys.
Now, I don't think it's necessary.
Okay.
I don't think it's necessary because I already explained multiple times.
But considering that what I'm doing, it's not common for people.
People think that I can risk without caring only because it's a demo.
Guys, please.
This one is connected.
I think you see the execution.
You see everything.
This is an interactive account.
Okay.
I don't think it's necessary in my community.
But there are people that think this is demo, really.
Or that it's not connected.
Okay.
This is live.
This is my mind.
It's not a problem.
Right.
Now we go to the market.
Now the market is getting a little bit choppy, guys.
The analysis...
I just want to see one second if my analysis was correct.
Because this one would have been an additional 15,000.
Just want to see if the reading is correct.
Okay.
Now...
This area that we marked.
Okay.
During the auction.
Plus...
Look at...
Look at the money this guy is making.
Sergi.
How much money are you making?
All connected accounts.
Okay.
Amazing.
Now...
The analysis was perfect.
The analysis was correct.
Uh...
It would have been better to put stop loss to breakeven and let's go like this.
But I think 5,000 in our pocket is still better.
I don't want to let the market take back what's mine.
And you know, I manage like this.
And now we are going to the final take profit.
If this goes guys is like a 10R for the day.
Even more.
Amazing.
And...
Building, building, building.
Look at this aggression on the short side.
Bam.
I want to show you...
Guys, how many of you took this short?
If you are in...
If you took it...
It's not a financial advice.
This is what I'm doing for myself.
But...
If you are in, it's time to take out.
Okay?
Because it's an amazing setup.
We are done for the day.
In terms of execution.
I just want to read the chat a little bit.
This session has to be one of the best.
Yeah, Martin.
It's really nice.
It's really nice session.
Okay.
It is definitely monopoly money when you are making 10,000 in an hour.
I did better.
There are some sessions I did 50 in an hour.
But it's not about this.
It's about...
Guys, in the session.
Okay?
In the...
In the service.
Okay?
We did two sessions where I managed to read.
Because it's really difficult to read and execute.
No?
We did the 20,000.
Okay?
But I'm waiting for the session.
It's not common.
But I'm waiting for the session where we will take maybe 10,000 in loss.
So I can show you also how my mind reacts.
How I manage.
How much I'm calm during the loss.
How I play with you.
Because...
This is trading.
This is also managing these kind of moments.
I cannot see the chat anymore.
Can you hear me, guys?
Let me refresh one second.
Guys?
But why?
Like, you see...
This is the mindset of people that then lose money.
the guy and says take one more trade okay guys i don't know if you understand that i don't know
if you understand that we took life life from this point watch the live okay we took life from this
point trailed here took profit one here reloaded on the 310 reloaded here and now we are here
if this session is not enough satisfaction for you you have a dopamine problem
if you still want to trade you have a dopamine problem trust me
okay they are rebalancing the moving the movement of yesterday they are rebalancing the movement of
yesterday now you want to understand why for me the short today was a short session let's go together
unreal i prefer to give you back money than to have this mind that mindset in my community
it's not about opportunities about making more money the guy say
what's the mindset you come here with the opportunity and money that you make it's related
it's totally really mamma mia oh my but it's slicing slicing
okay let me go with you too a really good explanation
it's pissing down it's pissing down today guys the collapse of the collapse
it's a rock ah but i have to tell you something i have to tell you something i was almost forgetting
then if you are not bored i want to tell you something it's really interesting about crypto
remove this okay
this one
this one is the profile framing okay so is the auction and how this is unfolding yeah is the auction
and now this is unfolding okay and this block till this peak here is where we have
the maximum concentration of volume for this distribution okay everything above this line it's
premium everything inside this line it's fair value everything below this line it's discount
okay how many of you maybe have the time to use deep charts and see the live
that i do and remember what i explained
i do live on monday usually where i can also give you the breakdown here is not a problem where i explain
okay what explain ah luca you are late we already made ten thousand dollars together
we already took seven or eight from charting setups in the momentum yeah
we we took some crazy session luca all this movement all this movement we took
i was inside from here i was inside from here and to the naysayer
guys look at this short look at this precision of this short loading and loading
ba-ra-bam reloaded here we took this one with the community together executed and managed and then i gave
them also this short on the 310. good guys now let's go back and i was saying we are premium in the curve here
so we expected
these movements okay it was what we were expecting this move down here
why because we are expensive in the curve the profile and if you want to be help you can merge
the profile that are one inside the other and you see the final trick this is what institutional players
thinks it's expensive okay and it's not finished here
because you can also use you can also use information about the commitment of traders report
that i will put in the war preparation section from next monday related to the fundamentals so i
explain to you how i imagine this service to grow first of all first of all there is the possibility
that this will be only the only three months that we'll make together then i will shut down why there
is this possibility because i don't like people that gets this huge amount of value and then come to
the chat after watching all the contents and making money and wanting the money back i think it's a big
this disrespect for me for the work i do okay and i think it's uh it's not it's not rewarding what i'm
doing okay and related to the service how i imagine the service to grow in the next two months
we will have our work preparation section that is where i will make fundamental analysis for you on the
nasdaq and on the indices in general using the institutional data of the commitment readers
report and using the profile framing so basically you have the analysis done by me the overview research
quality okay then you have two sessions with me where we see charting we see execution we see models
we see everything then you have a chat interaction in the battlefield section you have all my main trigger
for executing on the neural pattern recognition and you have the success of other students in the medal awards
do you like how we structure guys
this is the this is the idea this is the base
perfect okay this is the uh reason i took this short guys this is the reason i took this short from the
the top and also the institutional release was 14 000 contract short opened and 500 long closed okay
this means that institutions expect a follow-through on the downside and uh in this case as i explained to
you when we were here i marked this level for you because it was the bottom of the range it was where
i what i expect the market to start retracing and it's this level here the 25 000 oh we didn't reach yet
25 500 let me mark for you didn't reach this is where i can expect the market to start to go in a range
bound and to start retracing in this case and this is the reason we don't have enough space to try and
reload other short position okay this is the reason all these movements down was beautiful till we joined
it but now it's time to leave the grid at home and understand that here we can have a reaction how i know
that we can have a reaction let me do this for you hey that's what we are doing francesco we are going
through every every logic that i use
40 000 for the guy 40 000 for the guy amazing happy for you you made more than me today
guys look at the beauty of volume can you see it can you see it can you spot it
can you understand why i say the 25 500 look at this delta
this is the point where the majority of the buyers are concentrated and this is the point where i expect
today to have a stopping volume okay this is where i expect them to start to
not have an easy time slicing through it's not a level it's an area it's this cluster
okay now i can cancel
no i i don't get keep anything guys i'm explaining you exactly all my logic okay all my logic i explained
you the short and now i'm explaining to you from which level they will probably take out part of the
the profit and buyers will get back interested in this movement
okay all this
area that from price you can see here you see this explosion and load load load and then bam this
two phase accumulation area it's what's making
this level valuable
let's see if we can reach it
yeah more exposure to the market thank you steven more exposure to the market more chance to give
back profit if you don't have the condition guys you don't trade you need to understand this
okay you don't always have an edge so if you tell me
fabio execute here
i don't have any information okay
i don't have any information here because i don't see anything relevant to me i don't see
a clean space to go down because we have a block here okay we have a huge amount of orders here
at the same time i see that in this dead area in the middle there is nothing interesting
the speed of tape let's see it's dead okay it's dead it's not above average it's in the middle
even lower than middle so the auction is getting tired now and we are getting in a compression phase
and you know how the compression phase is structured probably we will manage to
see this also live but let me go through it before we go
so let's say that you have a
high delta level okay you have to consider two things the first one
is that this level is visible for all institutional players okay and these are actually executed orders
so when you have all these shorts loaded here this one is not only a point to
load eventually long but it's also a point to take profit from the cell
okay this one on the first touch create movement like this and here the game is decided because if
the action auction take control from a speed of day point of view you can go to rebalance all this
inefficiency that the market create not all but you can go to the main level of rebalance to the inefficiency
but what happens if this level gets broken if this level gets broken all these delta
are executed order they need to be closed what do you think will happen if 20 000 contract horizontally
placed gets closed what you have you have a squeeze okay and we still don't know this now because the
auction still not arrive on this level
that's important to understand
that's really important to understand let's go here
and let's see because now they are going there they will go really soon
it's super easy jace right
load deep trades view okay it's for everyone look you go on shared
i think it's on shared fabio valentini nasdaq deep trades view okay everything is here
you don't need to worry about anything and if you don't have i'm making my that work
um on something for people that cannot afford and a volume platform because during the year saying i i
think i spent more than 100 hours studying the volume spread analysis so i know that some of you
will like to have something on free platform like trading view okay and but i want to give you
something that is really valuable okay that if you cannot afford volume at least you have
something that gets as close as it's possible and this is what i'm preparing okay
170 000 across all account this session was even more an eye-opper than the other ones god
bless you thank you thank you amazing results anyway you are hedge fund level
um richard fabio just want to say thanks not sure and during i watch all the i'm only on prop account
but slowly building 61 000 of profit from the prop firm guys of course i cannot take an affiliate deal from
them of course they will ban me everywhere and soon they will ask you in the onboarding are you from
blood where sweat and scalp yes you don't enter in the proper
you will be banned you will be all banned guys start to build your account start to build your personal
account you will be all banned
amazing no i don't have information about this they they pay consistently there are props that are really
reliable guys the auction is getting here so the potential retracement is ready to start we are going
close to it we almost reached the level and i want to show you when they touch we want to show you the
uh donado if my ego was too big i will say yes you know what i say i say i don't know because
i don't see the interaction i need to see when they reach the level what happens i i don't know how to predict the
market guys but i know how to read them this one okay it's an auction that is telling me what they
want to do with information okay you know how many predictions there are here zero there is my skill on
reading remove from the prediction you don't need to predict where it will go next you need to read what
what the market is doing and when you have a reading okay you can go back and see okay which
level they can reach but based on data
we already took into consideration the distribution of the first three days
of the last three days and we saw what they can expect
yeah i have hours of experience that's true but it's nothing that you can
it's nothing special and everything that it's here you can do by yourself
best money ever spent amazing jay but please put a name so i can put a name to this complement
and you see they're starting
they are starting guys
they are starting
now this one could be interesting from a speed of day perspective let's see
see what they are doing this one seems like a multi-phase accumulation one
and they miss
they didn't even reach the level
they didn't even reach so you know what i expect a flash down to 500
25 500 with a lot of absorption and then the price starting to rebalance it
look at josh fabio when we would we enter along i need money i want to make money josh
it's normal that you lose in consolidation day but you cannot predict which day will be in consolidation
sometimes you have great fundamentals gate structure but the market gets closed inside
the range it's a range it's a range it's part of the range it's part of the game
it's part of the game
they want to put grandma on the long side but
i still think guys a lot of people maybe are going long on this but i think they will slice through
again because it's here where the volume is it's in this area it's in this area that it's concentrated the long
guys how many of you hold bitcoin how many of you have bitcoin in the portfolio
let's have a little bit of fun together
okay how would you react if i tell you that jeffrey epstein have direct relationship with the
with the developer of bitcoin
you need to go on one website guys it's it's cool it's called
jmail
dot world i put in the chat jmail dot word okay and it's letting you access like if this is your personal
gmail to ease on email and there are really suspicious email i i wasn't believing it yesterday
so i went to check directly in the department of justice of america
if he really had mail that he was worried about ripple when i saw that this is real
it's really freaking out guys
mainly i trade it okay so i have a high activity of buying and selling uh the one that i'm holding the most is ripple
the one that i have the most exposure is ripple i took it at 20 cents 0.20
it arrived to 3.5 3.4 now it's 1.6 1.5 something like this
and i'm interested in the possibility of the strategic reserve of xrp
but it's crazy that all this it's mentioned in the email
i was doing a little bit of fact checking to see if it's true it's crazy
i think you connected late josh i explained why the 25 500 level it's important
i explained step by step
see what i told you see what i told you probably this is the level of reload
they flash the buyers again
they flash the buyers here with a really strong move down
this move down gets
to the 25 500
and you start to see a printing of a green candle
i show you before ali i executed live on shorts so i show you how i manage the execution
but also we open the live with one position floating 6 000 i show you how i manage in real time
there's no
hobby i spend so much time studying but you read the market like a book
if you were to put the learning into priority steps what would it be
good question uh richard i would start from sensitive level of the market like we are doing together
and regime for example today regime was short because we started uh really close to the top
in precession so we needed a rebalance and i explained look at this look again look again look again
regime is look at the speed of tape you understand the flash
by the speed of tape they touch the area for the first time but they still didn't reach the
25 and 500 but you can understand from this that they are starting to have an obstacle
touched here touch 25 5000 they touch now you need to study the interaction
now you need to study the interaction
if they manage to break all this area they will flash and for break i mean the full so also this
white that is the minor boundaries the 25 460. we continue down guys it's a super directional day
if they break you don't have a long setup and this is important that you don't put your limit order
without understanding what you are doing because otherwise you get in your face the most amount of
aggression of the speed of date
we have 101 contract at the bottom
they're starting to be absorbed this one could be a reversal play really aggressive okay and really
dangerous but could be a reversal play in low risk
we want to try a reversal play guys low risk to go to the rebalance balance area it's up here
i go low risk
and i can start to load longs one one i load in the middle one i load on the downside
let me take 300 out of the market reload one here one here one here
let's make a total of four contract because the stop loss is really wide
no it's not i risk this one guys reversal trade i go really soft to boost the profit that i already
made for the day this one it's a fading setup
and it's a fading setup oh guys anyway we took the bottom
took the bottom took the bottom again
okay now it should give us the possibility to retrace let me put
my deep trades view
we have a good absorption from the sellers i load one here again one here one goes here
well let's try to make this 3000 additional
using this rebalance phase
see if i can load another one
yeah super super low risk guys relaxed
you know all trades of 500 1000 2000 at the end of the day if you position yourself really good
it can be another five to six thousand profits daily stacking to the ten thousand that you already
made now they will try from here to reload short this is the short reload level
let's see what they do
i think from here we go back down here let's see still don't see buyers
see a little bit of interest but nothing special
now how does this logic works this logic guys works on the facts that this green area is the level
where there was this high volume no so the first stop the first time you reach it gives you are a
bound with a huge probability so you can just build the position in a relaxed way to go up
okay this is really a relaxed way to go up
it would be amazing to see a little bit the speed of tape is weak guys
it's really weak nothing uh that makes sense to take
other risk in the long side but anyway let's do this for the purpose of the life but this one
is a trade that i'm just doing to show you a reversal it's nothing so good for me
let's load another contract here we have a total of four contract positions
i will reduce the stop loss once i get in the
the one once i lock the breakout here if we manage to lock the breakout
no not nervous at all if i don't get feel the order i don't get nervous i'm really relaxed guys
really really relaxed i start to see a little bit of interest you see how much this the price is moving
fast i think now the speed of tape shows something relevant the candle it's a little bit you see it's
a little bit above average but on the cell side so it means that a lot of cell orders are entering but
the price is stuck here okay so it could be that we see absorption from the price
let's see what we can do together
they reached their balance level the white one they didn't fill the other orders
they are not having at all an easy time going down this means that there is a little bit of volume on
the upside here and this is our mean reverting setup so if in the normal setup maybe you risk
eight contracts on the mean reverting use four okay even less
yeah of course i use the deep effort but now it's not necessary i'm just watching the interaction
now i should expect a little bit of interest one once they reach this 418 that got absorbed
this is nice let me reduce a little bit the exposure they they cannot tap into them
let me join with this with this this here and i put my risk below the 418
if they break the 418 i don't think it makes sense to to stay in the trade again
look how much aggression there is on the short side look how much aggression there is on the short
side they are deciding if they want to slice through you see you see what they are doing is a decisional
moment
buyers are dry are really dry here
i would expect that an absorption of this quality will bring a candle really aggressive on the upside
let's see if they manage to to follow through
see if they manage to do it
guys i feel really bad today i'm sorry but i have a really strong headache
let's see let's take the position out of these absorb buyers
let's they manage to go sorry guys
okay covering to zero
they took me out zero risk
let's see if we have another opportunity
are you understanding all the logic guys
is it clear
if we continue to make 5000 when we are right and lose zero when we are wrong there is no chance for
the market to survive you need to be fast guys you need to be fast and this is the reason i'm showing
you the the management you see what we say sometimes you are maybe um too cocky to you have too much ego
to say no wait the market is saying that the pressure is down why i'm keeping my long position
you understand from this movement that it doesn't make sense not to scale your profit because if the
auction of the buyers is continued and they broke we go up
okay it's an area not a not a label and s you see that they are still tapping into and
a little bit of absorption we see we can try another one again but only
if they manage to show some aggression of the buyers
the buyers for now buyers are sleepy guys and tired
you
i guess if the last green candle closed above them but as of now look speed of tape on the sellers
aggression on the sellers they want to break it they want to break it you see
there is no defense from the buyers at the moment
there is a continuous continuous sell auction
if they break this if they break this mid-level and this is maybe i can show you something new
yeah i can show you something new one logic when we are really close to the bottom okay that i can play
is the following one by stop uh too fast it's been too fast anyway by stop above the top
okay so you take the first movement out let's make it here one and two and you cover yourself really fast
on the bottom of the move for a reduced risk and you try to take we can also build the position
here here yes and you try to take the expansion up move okay and you go really fast risk free really fast
let's see let's reduce the stop loss below here because if this option fail we will break
let me remove the speed of tape
here we go
zero risk super fast now if they break we are covered if they retrace we have zero risk beautiful no
we will try to slice out of the market another
nine thousand
oh beautiful gap let's see if they don't manage to do a deep retracement and these buyers
reload here i can also secure another 2000 of profit let's let me see it depends on how much the auction
it's aggressive
you like this live management guys you understand the quality this is not easy to do while you are live
and managing a chat it's not easy at all
guys i don't feel good i have really a lot of headache wait a second i go to take water
here we go nice
or not bad let's cover below this 128
let's see if they manage to lift the auction
yeah we close this trade guys and then we did almost two hours let's see how it goes if the buyers
if we took the bottom and the buyers take control guys it's not 10 out of 10 it's an 11 out of 10.
now they should see a little bit of resistance on this white level
if they manage to slice it through it's possible it's really high probability that we go directly to
target here we go let me take other profit another 3 000 we are taking out
don't let the market steal money from you guys if you take a good shot
if you take a good shot remove the profit out of the table don't let it win over your emotions
i think we will squeeze above the red line i think we will squeeze that's the reason i'm
trying to capitalize on the squeeze if we fail we still make 3 300 it's an amazing day and it's
14 000 profits when i'm sick so i will not be mad at this it's okay it's totally okay guys let me see
if buyers take back control or if sellers manage to give them some aggression
oh look at this protection of the sellers how much they are aggressive
they took us out we close guys at 14 000 of profit for the session i still think we go
let me remark it i still think we go just want to show you if the analysis is correct and
what's what's the feedback on your first session majority view the other one
let me see if they reload here and restart
amazing how do you think go from here i think we will reload long again i think we will reload
this cluster of buyers it's interesting i want to see this interaction of the candle
i want to see this candle here if it can create a we can reject it's uh it's exactly what i would wait
this is exactly what i would wait anyway guys we only made profit we took zero stop loss we only
took breakeven i show you the life management we did a lot of charting a lot of trades a lot of theory
and one hour and forty i hope you like it uh i go to heal myself because really i feel horrible
and have an amazing day guys i hope you you enjoyed and see you on the next one